This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 2010, a history of the world in 100 Objects hosted by Neil McGregor premiered on BBC Radio 4 to great acclaim. It was a groundbreaking series that told a complex and interconnected history of the world through 100 objects housed in the British Museum collection. For 2026, BBC Studios decided they wanted to revamp and reimagine that ambitious series, this time focusing on the history of the history of the U.S. United States, coinciding with the 250th anniversary of the signing of the Declaration of Independence. To the great credit of the BBC, they thought that maybe British broadcasters weren't the best equipped to take on the curation of 100 objects that told the history of the United States. So that's when they reached out to me, lifelong American, Roman Mars.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2010年，由尼尔·麦格雷戈主持的《大英博物馆世界简史》在BBC广播四台首播，并大获成功。这是一个开创性的系列节目，通过大英博物馆馆藏的100件物品，讲述了一段复杂且相互关联的世界历史。对于2026年，BBC工作室决定重塑并重新构想这一宏大的系列，这次将重点放在美国历史的历程上，恰逢《独立宣言》签署250周年。BBC非常明智地认为，英国广播公司可能并不是策划这100件讲述美国历史物品的最佳人选。因此，他们找到了我——土生土长的美国人，罗曼·马尔斯。
With our 100 Object series, we knew we wanted to get out of the museum and focus on objects that were overlooked, thrown away, mass produced and misunderstood, not priceless museum pieces, but the everyday things that provide a portal into stories about what America means to itself and to the world at large. But from the beginning, I knew I needed sage advice to do the job right. And so I sought the council of the original 100 Objects host, Neil McGregor. Here's our conversation. What I was hoping you could do to begin with is taking back to January 2010, a history of the world in 100 objects is launching. It starts with a mummy that you saw as a boy. Were you aware
在我们的“100件物品”系列中，我们知道我们想走出博物馆，专注于那些被忽视、被丢弃、大规模生产和被误解的物品，而不是那些无价的博物馆藏品，而是那些为我们提供了一扇窗口，让我们了解美国对自己以及对整个世界意味着什么的日常事物。但从一开始，我就知道我需要明智的建议才能做好这项工作。因此，我寻求了最初的“100件物品”主持人尼尔·麦格雷戈的建议。这是我们的对话。我希望你首先能带我们回到2010年1月，《大英博物馆世界简史》即将推出的时候。它始于你儿时见过的一具木乃伊。你当时意识到
of the phenomenon that this was going to be when you started? No, absolutely not. Absolutely not. I was intimidated. We were all intimidated by the fact that the BBC had committed to a series of 100 programs. We had no idea how it was going to be received at all. And in a strange way, the project it began really almost as an internal project in the British Museum. What's interested me having come from the National Gallery, so a paintings collection, to a museum, the ambition of which was to show really the history of humanity through things, so not an art museum.
这将会成为一种现象吗？不，绝对没有。绝对没有。我当时很紧张。我们都被BBC承诺制作100集节目的事实吓到了。我们根本不知道它会受到怎样的评价。奇怪的是，这个项目最初几乎是大英博物馆内部的一个项目。我从国家美术馆（一个绘画收藏馆）来到这里，对一个旨在通过实物而非艺术品来展示人类历史的博物馆的雄心壮志感到非常感兴趣。
But to try to explore what it meant to put objects all over the world into one building. So it really began as a way of exploring what happens when you think of a museum as a place where different objects are exploring the same kind of human experience. And of all the things in the building, how did you choose the hundred?
但试图探索将世界各地的物品放在同一个建筑里意味着什么。所以它最初确实是一种探索，当你把博物馆看作是一个不同物品探索同一种人类经验的地方时，会发生什么。在馆内所有的物品中，你是如何选择这100件的？
Well, this was the greatest fun. The British Museum is created in the middle of the 18th century. Really, at that moment of the Enlightenment, when people begin to have a totally different notion of what humanity means, it's the physical expression of that enlightenment notion that there is one humanity. So what we decided to do was to try to organise the 100 objects.
嗯，这是最有趣的部分。大英博物馆创建于18世纪中叶。确实，在那个启蒙运动的时刻，当人们开始对人类的意义有了完全不同的概念时，它是那种“人类是一个整体”的启蒙思想的物理表达。所以我们决定尝试组织这100件物品。
Well, the BBC decided that there would be five programmes a week and there needed to be a theme for each week. And we wanted to go effectively from the beginning, the earliest hand tools made by anything that can roughly be called human right up to today. So that gave us the format. And that in each week we would go round the world. So you would take, let's say, you know, 1,000 BCE and look at a theme, let's say, power.
嗯，BBC决定每周播出五集，每一周都需要一个主题。我们想有效地从最初开始，从任何可以大致称为人类的生物制造的最早的手工工具一直讲到今天。这就是我们的格式。而且每周我们都会环游世界。所以，假设我们选取公元前1000年，然后看一个主题，比如“权力”。
And how do different societies represent power at 1,000 BCE? Yeah. But what it meant internally was that for every week, I would sit down with a curator from the Chinese collection, the Indian collection, Egyptian collection, the America's collection, and we would have to think of what objects might speak to each other. Of course, for academics and a particular discipline, this is a totally new way of thinking. There was no connection between ancient Egypt and ancient China. So no Egyptologist was likely to have asked what in my collection might relate to something
不同的社会在公元前1000年是如何表现权力的？是的。但在内部，这意味着每周我都要和中国馆、印度馆、埃及馆、美洲馆的策展人坐下来，我们必须思考哪些物品可以相互对话。当然，对于特定学科的学者来说，这是一种全新的思维方式。古埃及和古中国之间没有联系。所以没有埃及学家会问，我的收藏中有什么可能与
that's happening at the same time in China. Yeah. Because there's no connection. It's an anthropological question asked to, people who are historical scholars. And they found that completely thrilling because it's allowed them all really to look at familiar objects and ask a totally new kind of question
当时中国发生的事情有关。是的。因为没有联系。这是一个向历史学者提出的社会学问题。他们觉得这非常令人兴奋，因为它确实让他们所有人都能审视熟悉的物品，并提出一种全新的问题，
and suggest the commonalities of human behavior wherever we are. We all behave roughly, equally badly, equally well. And surprisingly, more or less in the same way. Yeah. Were there heated arguments? Was there, you know, table pounding when people were deciding which artifacts to... Curators don't normally pound the table.
并暗示无论我们在哪里，人类行为的共同点。我们所有人的表现大致上一样糟糕，也一样好。而且令人惊讶的是，或多或少以同样的方式。是的。有激烈的争论吗？当人们决定选择哪些文物时，有没有拍桌子？策展人通常不会拍桌子。
There was a certain amount of shrill advocacy. Okay. For my particular piece and a certain amount of sulking that others didn't make it. But it was normally extremely good timid. And because it was a new kind of conversation for all of them, very, very excited. And because what we were looking at was not the history of the world, but our history, a very peculiar one. And one of the histories we wanted to tell almost unspoken through it, because every object came from the museum,
确实存在一定程度的尖锐辩护。好吧。为了我特定的藏品，也有一定程度的生闷气，因为其他的没入选。但通常情况非常好。而且因为这对他们所有人来说都是一种新的对话，所以非常非常兴奋。而且因为我们所看的不是世界历史，而是我们的历史，一段非常独特的历史。我们想通过它讲述的几乎未言明的历史之一，因为每一件物品都来自博物馆，
was how did it happen that every one of these objects ultimately wound up in London? Was there a sense that you had to present a variety of objects? Because you could certainly do, you could do a history of the world. in a hundred coins. The joy of a collection at the British Museum is that you have so many different media in which humans articulate what matters to them, which is what all these things are about.
就是这些物品中的每一件最终是如何流落到伦敦的？你是否觉得必须呈现各种各样的物品？因为你当然可以做，你可以用100枚硬币来讲述世界历史。大英博物馆收藏的乐趣在于，人类有如此多不同的媒介来表达对他们重要的事情，而这正是所有这些东西的意义所在。
But the main purpose of doing history through objects was we wanted to allow people who don't have a voice to be heard. History is on the whole, used to mean, of course, just written history. That limits you immediately to that small bit of humanity that wrote. And it also limits you normally to the people that were in control. Because they were the ones that wrote the history. And they made sure it survived.
但通过物品进行历史研究的主要目的是，我们想让那些没有声音的人被听到。历史总的来说，过去当然意味着仅仅是书面历史。这立即将你限制在那一小部分会写作的人类身上。而且它通常也将你限制在掌权的人身上。因为他们是书写历史的人。而且他们确保了历史得以留存。
So part of our project was to have a history told by the people that had never been able to tell their story. By the makers. Through the things they're made. And that, I think, is really important. How do you give a voice to the voiceless of the past? Yeah, yeah. And particularly when you're talking about indigenous histories, then the objects become of huge importance as carrying the stories that weren't written and may not have survived in song or myth. So around the same time in 2010, I launched my show called 99% Invisible, and it's about architecture and design.
所以我们项目的一部分是让那些从未能讲述自己故事的人来讲述历史。通过制造者。通过他们制造的东西。我认为这真的很重要。你如何给过去那些无声的人以声音？是的，是的。特别是当你谈论原住民历史时，这些物品就变得极其重要，因为它们承载了那些没有被记录下来，可能也没有在歌曲或神话中流传下来的故事。所以大约在2010年同一时间，我推出了我的节目《99%隐形》，它是关于建筑和设计的。
and there was a certain kind of perversity to doing a radio show about architecture and design because there's hugely visual things. And you made the same choice to do a radio series on these things that most people take in with their eyes. Why did you do that? What did you get out of that? Well, at one level, it is totally counterintuitive, isn't it? We're talking about things, the materiality of things, how they're made, the skill with which they made, and yet you can't see it.
做一个关于建筑和设计的广播节目有一种反常感，因为这些是极其视觉化的东西。而你做出了同样的选择，对这些大多数人通过眼睛感知的东西制作了一个广播系列。你为什么要这样做？你从中得到了什么？嗯，在某种层面上，这完全是违反直觉的，不是吗？我们谈论的是事物，事物的物质性，它们是如何制造的，制造它们的技巧，但你却看不见它。
This is where I think the BBC radio, they know how to do this. But it's not just that. BBC has, I think, understood very profoundly and built on the fact that if you can only hear something, then you have to imagine what it is. And you can take possession of something you imagine much more fully than something you just see reproduced in front of you. is why I think we're nearly always disappointed when we see a film of a book
我认为这就是BBC广播知道如何做到的地方。但这不仅仅是这样。我认为BBC非常深刻地理解并建立在这样一个事实上：如果你只能听到某样东西，那么你就必须想象它是什么。而且你对想象出来的东西的占有感，远比仅仅看到它在你面前复制出来要完整得多。这就是为什么我认为当我们看一部书的电影时，我们几乎总是感到失望，
because in reading the book we've imagined the carriage of the place and they've become ours, part of the way we live and think. And the same with objects. If you have to do the mental imaginative work of creating the object for yourself, you are invested in it, you possess it in a way that is not really possible, I think, with just an image. I find that if you lead with the story of an object, you fall in love with it in a different way, whereas like your visual reaction to maybe seeing Rosetta Stone is like, I was expecting something more impressive or something like this. But you can tell the sort of the import of it, what it meant, the story of how it was created and, you know, even the mundane way which it existed.
因为在阅读这本书时，我们已经想象了那个地方的马车，它们已经成为了我们的一部分，成为了我们生活和思考方式的一部分。物品也是如此。如果你必须为自己做心理想象工作来创造这个物体，你就投入了其中，你以一种我认为仅仅通过图像无法实现的方式拥有了它。我发现如果你以一个物品的故事开头，你会以一种不同的方式爱上它，而你对看到罗塞塔石碑的视觉反应可能是：我期待着更令人印象深刻的东西，或者类似的东西。但你可以讲述它的重要性，它的意义，它被创造的故事，甚至它存在的那种平凡方式。
I think that's right. Because what we were really trying to tell was 100 biographies of an object. And because we only have one life. but objects have many, many lives. And what we got very interested in was the changing role of the object through time. In ways I don't know, nobody,
我想那是对的。因为我们真正试图讲述的是100个物品的传记。而且因为我们只有一次生命，但物品却有许多许多生命。我们非常感兴趣的是物品随时间推移而改变的角色。以我不知道的方式，没有人，
when the people carve the Rosetta Stone, this is a tax decree, it's a bit of tax law. And it's so boring. Beyond boring. Nobody carving that tax law in the three languages for administrative purposes in the Union
当人们雕刻罗塞塔石碑时，这是一个税收法令，它是一点税法。而且它太无聊了。无聊透顶。没有人为了行政目的用三种语言雕刻那条税法，
had any idea what it would one day come to mean. And there is something wonderful about that in an object, that the object can play a role that nobody could have guessed. Yeah, yeah. It makes their biographies much more engaged, much more alive, I think, than our own dull little predictable lives. Totally.
曾想到它有一天会意味着什么。物品中确实有一些美妙的东西，即物品可以扮演一个没有人能猜到的角色。是的，是的。我认为这让它们的传记比我们自己沉闷、微小、可预测的生活更投入，更生动。完全正确。
So when you wrote and conceived of the series and produced it, you know, you're the head director of this august institution, the British Museum, as people hold it in great esteem. And I wondered if you noticed your relationship with the public changed when you weren't director, Neil McGregor. You were my pal, Neil McGregor, who I'm invited into my home to tell me a story about a cool thing.
所以当你撰写、构思并制作这个系列时，你是大英博物馆这个受人尊敬的机构的馆长。我想知道，当你不再是馆长尼尔·麦格雷戈时，你是否注意到你与公众的关系发生了变化。你成了我的伙伴尼尔·麦格雷戈，我邀请你到我家给我讲一个关于酷东西的故事。
I think everybody's discovered that if you speak a lot on the radio, people feel they know you. And you must have been the same thing, that very disconcerting experience of actually being recognized in a lift by your voice. Yeah, yeah. The first time it happens, it's very, very peculiar. And one of the things that I think is interesting about it is that it allowed us to reaffirm that the public collections in Britain as in the United States are not the collections of the state, but the collections of the people.
我想每个人都发现，如果你在广播里说得很多，人们会觉得他们认识你。你一定也有同样的经历，那种在电梯里因为声音而被认出来的非常令人不安的经历。是的，是的。第一次发生这种情况时，非常非常奇特。我认为关于它有趣的一点是，它让我们重申，英国和美国的公共收藏不是国家的收藏，而是人民的收藏。
I mean, when the British Museum is created in the 7050s, the idea is that it should be the private collection of every citizen. not the collection of the king open to everybody. Completely different conception from the continental European model. So the idea of speaking directly into people's houses about their collection, their things. I mean, everything I was talking about belonged to the people listening to it. Why did you choose to examine the hundred objects chronologically? And what problems did that cause or what solutions did it provide? I think it has to be chronological.
我的意思是，当大英博物馆在1750年代创建时，其理念是它应该是每个公民的私人收藏，而不是向所有人开放的国王的收藏。这与欧洲大陆的模式完全不同。所以，直接向人们的家中讲述他们的收藏、他们的东西的想法。我的意思是，我谈论的一切都属于听它的人。你为什么选择按时间顺序检查这100件物品？这造成了什么问题，或者它提供了什么解决方案？我认为它必须是按时间顺序的。
because one of the things that happens across human issues is that we create a technology and then it helps us do something and then we become completely dependent on it. We can't live without it. The hand axe, the simple stone scraping hand axe is what lets us as humans live anywhere in the world. But then once you're there, you can't live without it. We've seen the same with mobile phones than the last 20 years. It opens something and then it creates what can be a very dangerous dependency. So that was one strand.
因为在人类问题中发生的一件事是，我们创造了一种技术，然后它帮助我们做某事，然后我们变得完全依赖它。没有它我们就无法生活。手斧，简单的石刮手斧，是让我们作为人类生活在世界任何地方的东西。但一旦你到了那里，你就离不开它了。在过去的20年里，我们在手机上也看到了同样的情况。它开启了一些东西，然后它创造了一种可能非常危险的依赖。所以这是一条线索。
And one of the key meta-nourages, I think, of any museum is the growing connectedness of the world. The fact that you can't tell a single story to use Chimamanda Adich's phrase. The story of the world is an interconnected story. So if you like, why we want to do it chronologically was to show that. constantly intensifying power of exchange curiosity about
我认为任何博物馆的关键元叙事之一是世界日益增长的联系。正如奇马曼达·阿迪奇所说，你不能只讲一个故事。世界的故事是一个相互关联的故事。所以如果你愿意，我们想按时间顺序做是为了展示这一点。不断强化的交流好奇心，
other places trade, greed, war, whatever but that has intensified steadily across the millennia until you can't really tell a single
其他地方的贸易、贪婪、战争等等，但这在几千年来稳步加强，直到你真的无法讲述一个单一的
narrative of a national story. And that was one of the points we wanted to make. The idea of a national history, I'm sorry to say
国家故事的叙事。这就是我们想表达的观点之一。国家历史的概念，我很抱歉地说，
that somebody was writing history in the United States, but the idea of and national history is unthinkable without situating that nation. Absolutely. In the global context.
有人在美国写历史，但国家历史的概念在不将该国家置于全球背景下的情况下是不可想象的。绝对是。
We are in agreement, for sure. But it does present this problem is like the beginning set of objects are all objects that are prehistoric. There's not written records about them. Like you have to sort of conceive of the story differently because there isn't a record of how it was made or why it was made. And so your set of stories really gets sort of limited. And then it opens up as you go along. I would disagree. I disagree. It narrows down the more we know about the... I guess that's true.
我们当然同意。但这确实提出了一个问题，即开始的一组物品都是史前物品。没有关于它们的书面记录。就像你必须以不同的方式构思故事，因为没有关于它是如何制造或为什么制造的记录。所以你的故事集确实变得有限了。然后随着你的深入，它就打开了。我不同意。我不同意。我们了解得越多，它就越狭窄……我想那是真的。
I mean, the whole point of, seems to be the central point of any kind of historical investigation is your poetic involvement with somebody else. That you have to think, what is it like to be somebody else? Because that's the basis of all tolerance. I mean, if you're like, the whole venture was really Gulliver's travels. You go off around the world. You find these astonishing things. things, wild things. But the point of Gulliver's travels is not
我的意思是，任何历史调查的核心似乎都是你对他人的诗意参与。你必须思考，成为别人是什么感觉？因为那是所有宽容的基础。我的意思是，如果可以的话，整个冒险实际上是《格列佛游记》。你环游世界。你发现了这些令人惊奇的东西，狂野的东西。但《格列佛游记》的重点不是
that the people in Brobding, Nag are huge and Lilliput-Tin. The point is that when you come back to England, you realize we're pretty peculiar. Yeah, yeah. We're the odd ones. Interesting. And to de-normalize, to remove yourself as the norm, is the precondition of tolerance. And that's what Gulliver's about.
布罗丁那格的人很大，小人国的人很小。重点是当你回到英国时，你意识到我们很奇特。是的，是的。我们是奇怪的人。有趣。去正常化，将自己从常态中移除，是宽容的前提。这就是《格列佛游记》的意义所在。
It's what the British Museum's about. And it's what the series was meant to be about. Yeah. That's interesting. I love that approach. One of the things I marveled at in the series is you're touching everything. You're always describing it as a first-hand experience. And for one reason you do that is it's a little more radiophonic. It allows you to have something happening as you're talking, so it's not just a lecture.
这就是大英博物馆的意义所在。这也是这个系列想要表达的意义。是的。这很有趣。我喜欢这种方法。我在这个系列中感到惊奇的一件事是，你触摸一切。你总是把它描述为一种第一手体验。你这样做的一个原因是它更具广播性。它允许你在说话时有事情发生，所以它不仅仅是一个讲座。
But the other part of it is it puts you in the first-person narrative of this object. It does. The difficult thing about that, which I found very hard to know how to manage, is where the object has, for the people who made it and possibly for people today as well its own kind of sacred existence
但它的另一部分是它让你进入了这个物品的第一人称叙事。确实如此。这其中困难的事情，我发现很难知道如何处理，是当这个物品对于制造它的人，以及可能对于今天的人来说，拥有它自己的一种神圣存在时，
its own life and how one ought then with proper reverence, proper respect hold or touch this object without having those beliefs and that took us into very interesting areas
它自己的生命，以及一个人应该如何以适当的敬畏、适当的尊重持有或触摸这个物品，而不拥有那些信仰，这把我们带入了非常有趣的领域，
of the extent to which you study can study objects in ways which are contrary to the belief patterns, belief assumptions of those who made them, how do we address an Australian original object, which may have sacred resonances in a respectful way? Interesting. Interesting. So one of the things I found there's this moment in the series quite laid into it where you
即你在多大程度上可以以违背制造者信仰模式、信仰假设的方式研究物品，我们如何以尊重的态度对待一件可能具有神圣共鸣的澳大利亚原住民物品？有趣。有趣。所以我在系列中发现了一个时刻，在很晚的时候，你
talk to David Hockney, which is the first person you talked to who made the person. the object that you're talking about, which is it's such a change compared to the rest of the series. What was that like? Well, it was very thrilling. We had, you know, I'd been waiting to get to an object made by somebody where we could speak to the maker.
和大卫·霍克尼交谈，这是你交谈的第一个制造了你正在谈论的物品的人，这与系列的其他部分相比是一个巨大的变化。那是什么感觉？嗯，非常令人兴奋。我们，你知道，我一直等着得到一件由我们可以与之交谈的人制造的物品。
The very first object was one and a half million years ago on the stone chopping tools. Obviously, but we had David Attenborough instead. Yeah, well, that's pretty good. Which is almost do to tell us, what's going on, how this fits into the animal-human differentiation.
第一件物品是150万年前的石切工具。显然，但我们有大卫·爱登堡代替。是的，嗯，那很不错。这几乎是为了告诉我们，发生了什么，这如何融入动物与人类的区分。
But it was wonderful with David Hockney because the objects we were talking about were a series of prints he'd made really about gay life in Egypt, the poems of Kavafi. And we chose the objects for several reasons. In the 20th century, we wanted to choose objects that would address the questions of new kinds of freedom. So we had votes for women, it was one, gay rights, another. We wanted to, of course, to present what it was like to make the objects and why David himself, obviously, very committed to gay rights, what it meant to him to read the poems, above all, and then to make the prints,
但和大卫·霍克尼在一起很棒，因为我们谈论的物品是他制作的一系列关于埃及同性恋生活的版画，卡瓦菲的诗歌。我们选择这些物品有几个原因。在20世纪，我们想选择能够解决新自由问题的物品。所以我们有妇女投票权，这是一个，同性恋权利，另一个。我们当然想展示制作这些物品是什么感觉，为什么大卫本人显然非常致力于同性恋权利，阅读这些诗歌对他意味着什么，最重要的是，然后制作这些版画，
and then what it would mean to him to have the prints used, looked at, and spread the campaign, advanced the campaign, for gay rights internationally. But it was a, as you say, it was a real turning point. Yeah. To be able to speak to the maker for the first time. There was also, there was a lot of excitement for the choice of the final 100th object. You deliberately didn't reveal it until the last minute.
然后让这些版画被使用、被观看、传播运动、推进国际同性恋权利运动对他意味着什么。但正如你所说，这是一个真正的转折点。是的。第一次能够与制造者交谈。对于最后第100件物品的选择也有很多兴奋。你故意直到最后一刻才揭晓它。
You invited listeners to suggest it. What was it? Why did you choose it? And how did people react to it? We're enormous fun trying to decide what was the last. last object to choose. We wanted to choose an object that spoke to a totally globalised world. We also wanted to end, of course, on a note that would be hopeful. So we eventually came down to two objects. One was a football shirt. Okay. A football shirt of a West African, a Frogba,
你邀请听众建议它。它是什么？你为什么选择它？人们对此有何反应？我们决定最后一个选择什么非常有趣。我们想选择一件能够与完全全球化的世界对话的物品。我们当然也想以一个充满希望的音符结束。所以我们最终确定了两个物品。一个是足球衫。好的。一件西非的足球衫，德罗巴，
a Francophone, West African, who was the great star of Chelsea. Yeah. And Chelsea was owned by Russian oligarch Bridget. And the football shirt had been made illegally in China but bought in Latin America. So that object seemed to
一个法语西非人，他是切尔西的伟大球星。是的。而切尔西是由俄罗斯寡头布里奇拥有的。这件足球衫是在中国非法制造的，但在拉丁美洲购买的。所以那件物品似乎
us to pull together quite a lot of the world as it now is. What we ultimately went for was slightly more serious. It was a solar panel rechargeable mobile phone because the mobile phone seemed to us to be the equivalent of the hand axe, the chopping tool.
把我们现在所处的相当多的世界联系在一起。我们最终选择的是稍微严肃一点的。它是一部太阳能充电手机，因为手机在我们看来似乎相当于手斧，切削工具。
The first technology that had enabled humans to move around the world. And this latest one that enabled humans to communicate around the world. We were interested in it because it's become, of course, in so many areas, an element of emancipation, particularly women, enabling women to bank, enabling women to trade. And, of course, the other dimension of solar power, which we wanted to bring in, is that in political terms,
第一种使人类能够在世界各地移动的技术。而这最新的一种使人类能够在世界各地交流。我们对它感兴趣是因为它在许多领域当然已经成为一种解放的元素，特别是女性，使女性能够储蓄，使女性能够交易。当然，我们想引入的太阳能的另一个维度是，在政治层面上，
this has become a very important thing because in large areas of Africa and Asia, the electric currents, cables, two areas, could be controlled by political bosses. and areas could either be not cabled or have cables removed or whatever. The solar power, at a stroke, removes that power, removes that political control. So it seemed to us to be in many, many ways, an emblem of liberation, an emblem of the growing technologies which change our lives and then we become dependent on them. It's also about talking.
这已经成为一件非常重要的事情，因为在非洲和亚洲的大片地区，电流、电缆、两个区域，可能受到政治老板的控制。区域可能要么没有电缆，要么电缆被移除等等。太阳能，一举消除了那种权力，消除了那种政治控制。所以它在我们看来在许多许多方面是解放的象征，是改变我们生活然后我们变得依赖它们的技术增长的象征。它也关于交谈。
and, of course, many people listen to the BBC on their mobile phone, so it was also a nod to patron. Absolutely. Radio is the most important thing. The BBC. Of course, you know where your bread is butter. That makes sense. But it was also the solar-powered lamp,
当然，许多人在手机上收听BBC，所以这也是对赞助人的致意。绝对是。广播是最重要的事情。BBC。当然，你知道你的面包在哪里涂黄油。这说得通。但它也是太阳能灯，
which also extended the day. And it's all about this sort of individualized freedom and the ability of this technology frees you for all kinds of things. That's what we wanted to, again, finish on how these technologies do, unquestioning, make life better. Yeah. Because the solar panel will give you the lamp, which means you can work at home if you're a student without address, whatever. And it also means you don't need to burn for your lighting materials, which are likely to cause you lung problems and health difficulties. Yeah.
它也延长了白天。这一切都关于这种个性化的自由，以及这种技术使你从各种事情中解放出来的能力。这就是我们想再次结束的地方，关于这些技术如何毫无疑问地让生活变得更好。是的。因为太阳能电池板会给你灯，这意味着如果你是一个没有地址的学生，你可以在家学习，无论什么。这也意味着你不需要为了照明材料而燃烧，这很可能会导致你的肺部问题和健康困难。是的。
So in every way, it's potentially a good thing. And we wanted to end on a good 100th thing. I'm interested in what you think of the series' legacy now. It's an early example of podcasting being really successful. I think it had more listeners globally than it did inside of the UK. What do you think of the legacy of the show? Well, we've been as surprised by the legacy, as we were by the response initially. I think it has definitely had an impact in terms of reminding.
所以从各方面来看，它可能是一件好事。我们想以一件好的第100件东西结束。我对你现在如何看待这个系列的遗产很感兴趣。它是播客非常成功的一个早期例子。我认为它在全球的听众比在英国国内的听众还要多。你如何看待这个节目的遗产？嗯，我们对遗产感到惊讶，就像我们最初对反应感到惊讶一样。我认为它在提醒人们方面绝对产生了影响，
finding people that the everyday object has its own biography, its own history. And that takes you back to the dignity of the maker and the user. So what it does as a history is it takes away the great moment that we're taught. You don't have the Battle of Waterloo. Yes. Why would it figure? Absolutely. Because that's not the kind of history.
人们发现日常物品有它自己的传记，它自己的历史。这把你带回了制造者和使用者的尊严。所以作为历史，它所做的是消除了我们被教导的伟大时刻。你没有滑铁卢战役。是的。为什么它会出现？绝对是。因为那不是那种历史。
So it opens the way to other histories told by other people. Yeah. And that's why A history versus D history. Exactly. And that was very important. One of the slightly, it's been translated into a lot of languages, the book. One of the vexing things is in some countries, some translations, the publisher insisted on making it the history.
所以它为其他人讲述的其他历史打开了道路。是的。这就是“一种历史”与“历史”的区别。正是如此。这非常重要。稍微有点，它被翻译成很多语言，这本书。令人烦恼的事情之一是在一些国家，一些翻译中，出版商坚持把它变成“历史”。
So maybe in translation, the and R mean different. things in different languages. Yeah. You know, this idea of a history and the fact that objects mean different things to different people, this came up a lot, as you've alluded to already, you would talk to folks who would differ
所以也许在翻译中，“一种”和“历史”在不同语言中意味着不同的东西。是的。你知道，这种“一种历史”的想法，以及物品对不同人意味着不同东西的事实，这经常出现，正如你已经提到的，你会和那些不同意的人交谈
from even designation of it being an object at all. What is that like navigating that in the storytelling? It is difficult, of course, and it's where the... It's quite useful to be able to say, well, the BBC only gave us 13 and a half minutes for this. So you can point to the controversy.
甚至不同意它是一个物品的称呼。在讲故事中导航那是什么感觉？这当然很困难，这就是……能够说“嗯，BBC只给了我们13分半钟的时间来做这个”是很有用的。所以你可以指出争议。
You don't want to fully adjudicate it. Exactly. But it's a very real one, and it's very central to museum experience. And that's one of the difference, clearly, between the series we were doing your series. We were talking very much about objects in a museum to be presented to the public. But in a museum, the question, for instance, should some objects be shown at all? Yeah. when it will cause offense to members of a community from which in the past they came.
你不想完全裁决它。正是如此。但这是一个非常真实的问题，它对博物馆体验非常核心。这就是我们正在做的系列和你的系列之间明显的区别之一。我们谈论的是博物馆里的物品，要呈现给公众。但在博物馆里，问题是，例如，有些物品是否应该展示？是的。当它会冒犯过去它们来源的社区成员时。
That's a very delicate thing, because what you're really talking about there are putting limits on the quest for knowledge. Am I not to be allowed to pursue certain lines of inquiry because it might offend your beliefs? that's a huge question. It is, yeah. The 18th century was very brisk about this. Yeah. Partly because it was really about the constraints of the churches, and it was saying that the constraints put on academic scientific research
这是一个非常微妙的事情，因为你真正谈论的是对知识追求的限制。我不被允许追求某些探究路线，因为它可能会冒犯你的信仰吗？这是一个巨大的问题。是的，确实。18世纪对此非常干脆。是的。部分原因是它确实是关于教会的约束，它是在说教会对学术科学研究施加的约束
by the churches were simply unacceptable, and that you had to go on pursuing the questions, even if the faithful were distressed. We can't take that position with the same confidence or we might choose not take it at all today in relation to other beliefs outside the European experience particularly.
是完全不可接受的，你必须继续追求这些问题，即使信徒感到痛苦。我们今天不能以同样的信心采取这种立场，或者我们可能选择根本不采取它，特别是在欧洲经验之外的其他信仰方面。
It's a, I think, a very big philosophical question. Yeah, yeah. And I don't know the answer. Yeah. But it's a question that comes again and again, particularly, of course, in areas of the natural world and of human history.
我认为这是一个非常大的哲学问题。是的，是的。我不知道答案。是的。但这是一个一次又一次出现的问题，特别是在自然世界和人类历史领域。
Yeah, yeah. Because even, like, putting a date, on a Clovis, the sphere point of Clovis' peer point, people don't want to hear a date associated with it. They don't want to hear, you know, that people arrived. This was a very interesting discussion because, as I understand it, the archaeological evidence and the DNA evidence points to the fact that the Americas are peopled from Northeast Asia sometime around 15,000 years ago. That, of course, is a historical account that is at odds with the traditional beliefs of many indigenous Americans.
是的，是的。因为即使是给克洛维斯矛尖定日期，人们也不想听到与之相关的日期。他们不想听到，你知道，人们到达了。这是一个非常有趣的讨论，因为据我所知，考古证据和DNA证据表明，美洲是在大约15000年前从东北亚有人居住的。这当然是一个与许多美洲原住民传统信仰相冲突的历史叙述。
How one presents the one without offending the other is a very serious question. Yeah. We decided simply to allude to it, but not to explore it, but to present what we believe the thing tells us. Yeah, yeah. But it's a very, I don't know whether that was the right decision. Well, I don't know what other decision you could quite make, honestly. Like, I don't, I don't know. Because you have two irreconcilable understandings of the relationship between the people in the place and the story of the world.
如何呈现一个而不冒犯另一个是一个非常严肃的问题。是的。我们决定简单地提到它，但不去探索它，而是呈现我们认为它告诉我们的东西。是的，是的。但这非常……我不知道那是否是正确的决定。嗯，我不知道你还能做出什么其他决定，老实说。就像，我不知道。因为你有两种关于人与地方的关系以及世界故事的不可调和的理解。
Yeah. And we have different views of, you know, how reverent to sort of treat that object. I mean, like, you treated the object with great reverence. Like, it was super important. But Clovis point is there that meant, you know, 80% of the megafauna, like, you know, was gone. It's death to the mammoth. You know, it's all interesting and important stuff, but it's, they are not.
是的。我们有不同的观点，你知道，如何以某种敬畏的方式对待那个物品。我的意思是，你以极大的敬畏对待这个物品。就像，它超级重要。但克洛维斯矛尖在那里意味着，你知道，80%的巨型动物，就像，你知道，消失了。这对猛犸象来说是死亡。你知道，这都是有趣且重要的事情，但它们不是。
And so you just have to do your best to present the signs of it, I swear. I think that's as much as one can do in this kind of format. Yeah. So we're now making a history of the U.S. and 100 objects. If you had an advice for like things that you would think, I must, you must include. First of all, we're not going chronological. I decided this from the very beginning because I needed the freedom to jump around. And we also were like, we're open, we've sort of conceived of 25 or 30, and we have it open and we're trying to solicit responses from people.
所以你只需要尽力呈现它的迹象，我发誓。我认为在这种格式中，一个人能做的就是这些。是的。所以我们现在正在制作《美国历史与100件物品》。如果你有什么建议，比如你认为你必须包括的东西。首先，我们不是按时间顺序的。我从一开始就决定了这一点，因为我需要跳跃的自由。而且我们也像，我们是开放的，我们构思了25或30个，我们保持开放，我们试图征求人们的反应。
So what is the type of thing that you think from your experience in the first 100 Object series is important to include? You're talking about the history from... It's kind of 1776. You know, it could be things that lead into it. I think what would be interesting is an outsider. We all know the things that came, as well, from the Europeans settling into America. But the things that came from America, for instance, tobacco. Yeah, yeah.
那么，根据你在第一个“100件物品”系列中的经验，你认为哪种类型的东西很重要？你谈论的是从……的历史。大约是1776年。你知道，它可能是导致它的东西。我认为作为一个局外人会很有趣。我们都知道欧洲人定居美国带来的东西。但来自美国的东西，例如烟草。是的，是的。
I mean, there is something that America gave the world that changed the world. Absolutely, absolutely. And smoking tobacco appears almost had begun in the territory of the United States. What object you would choose, I don't know, but that's how it's completely changed the world. That's a good point. And certainly in my childhood in the 50s and 60s, I mean, you couldn't be a credible teenager without a cigarette. And it could be a French one, but it could just easy be a lucky strike or whatever. But even the French ones were, of course, American derived.
我的意思是，美国给世界的东西改变了世界。绝对，绝对。吸烟烟草似乎几乎始于美国领土。你会选择什么物品，我不知道，但这就是它如何彻底改变了世界。这是一个好观点。当然，在我50和60年代的童年时期，我的意思是，没有香烟你就不可能是一个可信的青少年。它可以是法国的，但它也可以很容易是好彩或其他。但即使是法国的，当然也是美国衍生的。
So that kind of notion. And the same with blue jeans. Why did blue jeans represent a kind of freedom? I mean, when we were talking about the new freedoms, political and economic and sexual, we read objects that told those stories, I mean, the coins for votes for women, Hockley's, Prince, whatever, blue jeans and cigarettes mean something the same. It does. But what are the about, and how does that happen?
所以那种概念。蓝色牛仔裤也是如此。为什么蓝色牛仔裤代表了一种自由？我的意思是，当我们谈论新的自由，政治、经济和性自由时，我们阅读了讲述这些故事的物品，我的意思是，妇女投票权的硬币，霍克尼的版画，无论什么，蓝色牛仔裤和香烟意味着同样的东西。确实。但它们是关于什么的，这是怎么发生的？
I mean, that seems to me something. That's where the history of the US is the history of the world. I hope some of your objects will be chosen, really, to make that. point. That's right. I mean, you've heard a couple of the early episodes. One of the ones that's that's sort of like the cigarettes and blue jeans, but maybe like not quite as known is this 60-degree threaded screw, which is an object that has very little outward significance to people, but really dominated and changed the world. I find that completely fascinating, because it's a totally different way of using an object from what we were doing. I mean, you were taking an
我的意思是，这对我来说似乎是某样东西。这就是美国历史是世界历史的地方。我希望你的一些物品会被选择，真的，来表达这一点。那是对的。我的意思是，你听过几集早期的节目。其中一个，就像香烟和蓝色牛仔裤，但可能没有那么出名，是这个60度螺纹螺丝，这是一个对人们几乎没有外在意义的物品，但确实主导并改变了世界。我发现这完全令人着迷，因为它是一种与我们正在做的完全不同的使用物品的方式。我的意思是，你正在采取一个
algebra, I mean, almost any screw would have done. Any screw, yeah. No particular screw. And using it to plot how the US dislodged the UK as the industrial determinant of the world. And that huge shift in economic political military power can all be read through the discussions about how to standardise globally, the thread on the screw. I knew nothing about it at all at all at all. And it was completely fascinating. And, of course, it's not at all surprising once it's spelled out, like all these things, the minute you're told you can understand, of course, that's what would have happened. It was brilliant. Oh, thank you. Thank you. Brilliant. So do you have any advice for me as I'm embarking on this? Like, is there a moment that I should be aware of? Is it like object number 68 where you're just like where it's... Yes, that's exactly the object, at which you will wonder.
代数，我的意思是，几乎任何螺丝都可以。任何螺丝，是的。没有特定的螺丝。并用它来绘制美国如何取代英国成为世界工业决定因素。而经济、政治、军事力量的巨大转变都可以通过关于如何在全球范围内标准化螺丝螺纹的讨论来解读。我对此一无所知。这完全令人着迷。而且，当然，一旦解释清楚，一点也不令人惊讶，就像所有这些事情一样，一旦你被告知，你就能理解，当然，这就是会发生的事情。这很棒。哦，谢谢。谢谢。太棒了。那么，当我开始这个项目时，你有什么建议吗？比如，有一个时刻我应该注意吗？就像第68号物品，你只是觉得……是的，那正是那个物品，你会怀疑。
Why am I doing this? Can I bear to go on? Am I ever going to get to the end? Is anybody still listening? I should watch out for that moment. The answer is yes. You will and they are. And we need it. So thank you.
我为什么要这样做？我能忍受继续吗？我还能走到最后吗？还有人在听吗？我应该注意那个时刻。答案是肯定的。你会的，他们也在听。我们需要它。所以谢谢。
Neil McGregor, thank you so much for talking with me. I had such a good time. Thank you. And now here's an episode of a history of the world in 100 objects. Enjoy. Every day I walk through the Egyptian sculpture gallery at the British Museum. And every day there are tour guides speaking every imaginable language, addressing groups of visitors who are craning to see the object that I'll be talking about in this program.
尼尔·麦格雷戈，非常感谢你和我交谈。我玩得很开心。谢谢。现在是《大英博物馆世界简史》的一集。享受吧。每天我都会走过大英博物馆的埃及雕塑馆。每天都有导游用各种可以想象的语言，向挤着看我将在本节目中谈论的物品的游客群体讲话。
It's on every visitor's itinerary, and with the mummies, it's the most popular object in the British Museum. Why? To look at, it is decidedly dull. It's a grey stone about the size of one of those large suitcases you see people trundling around on wheels. at airports, and the rough edges show that it's been broken from a larger stone, with the fractures cutting across the text that covers one side. And when you read that text, it's pretty dull too. It's mostly bureaucratic jargon about tax concessions. But as so often in the museum, appearances are deceiving, because this dreary bit of broken granite has played a starring
它在每个游客的行程中，和木乃伊一起，它是大英博物馆最受欢迎的物品。为什么？看起来，它绝对沉闷。它是一块灰色的石头，大约有你在机场看到人们拖着轮子走的那种大行李箱那么大，粗糙的边缘显示它已经从一块更大的石头上破碎下来，裂缝切过了覆盖一侧的文字。当你阅读那段文字时，它也很无聊。它大多是关于税收减免的官僚术语。但正如博物馆中经常出现的那样，外表是具有欺骗性的，因为这块沉闷的破碎花岗岩在三个迷人且不同的故事中扮演了主角。
role in three fascinating and different stories. The story of the Greek kings who ruled in Alexandria after Alexander the Great conquered Egypt, the story of the French and British imperial competition across the Middle East, after Napoleon invaded Egypt, and the extraordinary but peaceful scholarly contest that led to the most famous decipherment in history, the cracking of hieroglyphics. In the Memphis decree,
亚历山大大帝征服埃及后在亚历山大港统治的希腊国王的故事，拿破仑入侵埃及后法国和英国在整个中东的帝国竞争的故事，以及导致历史上最著名破译——象形文字破解的非凡但和平的学术竞赛的故事。在孟菲斯法令中，
we find a Greek view of the world in Egyptian terms. I think it's quite weird, why you would put this sort of a statement, which is basically a statement of tax exemption, on such a heavy stone. I mean, 760 kilograms. Why did they do that? A history of the world in 100 objects. The Rosetta Stone.
我们发现了以埃及术语表达的希腊世界观。我认为这很奇怪，为什么你会把这种声明，基本上是税收豁免声明，放在这么重的石头上。我的意思是，760公斤。他们为什么要那样做？《大英博物馆世界简史》。罗塞塔石碑。
Erected in 196 BC. Fandot El Rashid, Egypt. This is a week of objects connected to shifting empires and legendary rulers. from Alexander the Great to the Emperor Augustus. Over 2,000 years ago, from the Mediterranean and the Middle East to India and China, these leaders found different ways of physically projecting their power and their authority. Today's programme is particularly fascinating, though, because it's a special case. It's about a ruler who's not strong, but weak,
公元前196年立于埃及拉希德。这一周我们关注的是与更迭的帝国和传奇统治者相关的文物，从亚历山大大帝到奥古斯都皇帝。两千多年前，从地中海、中东到印度和中国，这些领导人以不同的方式在物质层面展示他们的权力和权威。今天的节目特别引人入胜，因为它是一个特殊的案例。它讲述的是一位并不强大，反而软弱的统治者，
a king who has to bargain for and protect his power by borrowing the invincible strength of the gods, or, more precisely, the priests. were in Egypt, with Ptolemy V, a Greek boy king who came to the throne as an orphan in 205 BC at the age of six. Ptolemy the 5th was born into a great dynasty. The first Ptolemy was one of Alexander the Great's generals, who around a hundred years earlier had taken over Egypt following Alexander's death. The Ptolemies didn't trouble to learn Egyptian. They simply made all their officials speak Greek,
一位不得不通过借用神灵——或者更准确地说是祭司——的无敌力量来争取和维护权力的国王。我们现在身处埃及，主角是托勒密五世。他是一位希腊裔的少年国王，公元前205年，年仅六岁的他沦为孤儿并登基。托勒密五世出生于一个伟大的王朝。第一位托勒密是亚历山大大帝的将军之一，在大约一百年前亚历山大去世后接管了埃及。托勒密家族并不费心去学习埃及语，他们只是要求所有的官员都说希腊语，
and so Greek would be the language of state administration in Egypt. Egypt for a thousand years. Perhaps their greatest achievement was to make their capital city, Alexandria, into the most brilliant metropolis of the Greek-speaking world. For centuries, it was second only to Rome. It was a cosmopolitan magnet for goods, people and ideas. The vast library of Alexandria was built by the Ptolemies. In it, they planned to collect all the world's knowledge, and Ptolemy's one and two created the famous Pharos Lighthouse, which became one of the seven wonders of the world. Such a lively, diverse city needed strong leadership. When Ptolemy V's father died suddenly, leaving the boy as king, the dynasty and its control of Egypt looked fragile.
因此，希腊语成为了埃及的国家行政语言，并持续了千年之久。他们或许最伟大的成就，是将首都亚历山大港打造成为希腊语世界中最辉煌的大都市。几个世纪以来，它的地位仅次于罗马。它是一个汇聚商品、人口和思想的国际化磁石。亚历山大图书馆就是由托勒密家族建造的，他们计划在其中收集全世界的知识。托勒密一世和二世还建造了著名的法罗斯灯塔，它成为了世界七大奇迹之一。这样一座充满活力、多元化的城市需要强有力的领导。当托勒密五世的父亲突然去世，留下年幼的他继位时，这个王朝及其对埃及的控制看起来摇摇欲坠。
The boy's mother was killed, the palace was drawn by soldiers, and there were revolt throughout the country, which delayed the young Ptolemy's coronation for years. It was in these volatile circumstances that Ptolemy V issued the Rosetta Stone, and others like it. Stone is not unique, there are another 17 similar inscriptions quite like it, all in three languages, and all proclaiming the greatness of the Ptolemies. These were put up in major temple complexes across Egypt. The Rosetta Stone was made in 196 BC on the first anniversary of the coronation of Ptolemy V, by then a teenager. It's a decree issued by Egyptian priests, ostensibly to mark the coronation and to declare Ptolemy's new status as a living. God. Divinity went with the job of being a pharaoh. The priests had given Ptolemy a full Egyptian
这位少年的母亲被杀，宫殿遭到士兵洗劫，全国各地爆发起义，这使得年轻的托勒密加冕典礼推迟了多年。正是在这种动荡的环境下，托勒密五世发布了罗塞塔石碑以及其他类似的石碑。这块石碑并非独一无二，还有另外17块类似的铭文，它们都用三种语言书写，都在宣扬托勒密家族的伟大。这些石碑被竖立在埃及各地的主要神庙建筑群中。罗塞塔石碑制作于公元前196年，即托勒密五世加冕一周年之际，当时他已是少年。这是一份由埃及祭司发布的法令，表面上是为了纪念加冕典礼，并宣布托勒密作为在世神灵的新身份。神性是法老职责的一部分。祭司们为托勒密举行了完整的埃及式
coronation at the sacred city of Memphis, and this greatly strengthened his position as the rightful ruler of Egypt. But there was a trade-off. Ptolemy may have become a god, but to get there, he'd had to negotiate some very unheavenly politics with his extremely powerful Egyptian priests. Dorothy Thompson, Emeritus Professor at Cambridge University, explains. The occasion which resulted in this decree was in some respects a change. There had been previous decrees and they take much the same form. But in this particular reign, the reign of a very young king whose kingdom was under attack for many quarters, one of the clauses of the Memphis decree, the Rosetta Stone, is that priests should no longer come every year to Alexandria. Alexandria was the new Greek
加冕典礼，这极大地巩固了他作为埃及合法统治者的地位。但这是一场交易。托勒密可能成为了神，但为了达到这一目的，他不得不与他极其强大的埃及祭司们进行了一些非常世俗的政治谈判。剑桥大学名誉教授多萝西·汤普森解释道：导致这项法令颁布的场合在某些方面是一种改变。此前也有过类似的法令，它们的形式大同小异。但在这一特定的统治时期，在一个王国受到多方攻击的年轻国王统治下，孟菲斯法令（即罗塞塔石碑）的条款之一是，祭司们不再需要每年都前往亚历山大港。亚历山大港是新的希腊
capital. Instead, they could meet at Memphis, the old centre of Egypt. This was new, and it may be seen perhaps, as a concession on the part of the royal household. The priests were critical in keeping the hearts and minds of the Egyptian masses on side for Ptolemy, and the Rosetta Stone was their reward. Not only does the decree allow the priests to remain in Memphis rather than coming to Alexandria, it also gives them a number of very attractive tax breaks. Of course, no teenager is likely to have thought this up. Somebody behind the throne was clearly thinking strategically on the boy's behalf, and more importantly, on the dynasty's behalf.
首都。相反，他们可以在埃及的旧中心孟菲斯会面。这是新的举措，或许可以被视为王室的一种让步。祭司们对于争取埃及大众支持托勒密至关重要，而罗塞塔石碑就是对他们的奖赏。该法令不仅允许祭司留在孟菲斯而不是前往亚历山大港，还给予了他们一些非常有吸引力的减税优惠。当然，没有任何一个少年能想出这些。王座背后显然有人在为这位少年，更重要的是为这个王朝进行战略性思考。
So the stone is simultaneously an expression of power and of compromise, although to read the whole content is about as thrilling as reading a new EU treaty written simultaneously in several languages. The content is bureaucratic, priestly and dry, But that, of course, is not the point. What matters about the Rosetta Stone is not what it says, but that it says it three times and in three different languages. In classical Greek, the language of the Greek rulers and the state administration,
因此，这块石碑既是权力的表达，也是妥协的产物，尽管阅读其全部内容就像阅读一份同时用多种语言写成的欧盟新条约一样枯燥。其内容是官僚主义的、祭司式的且干巴巴的。但当然，重点不在这里。罗塞塔石碑的重要性不在于它说了什么，而在于它用三种不同的语言说了三次。用古典希腊语，即希腊统治者和国家行政部门的语言，
and then in two forms of ancient Egyptian, the everyday writing of the people known as Demotic, and the priestly hieroglyphics, which have for centuries baffled Europeans. It was the Rosetta Stone that changed all that. and while the text of the stone itself is pretty unexciting, it dramatically opened up the entire world of ancient Egypt. By the time of the Rosetta Stone, 196 BC, hieroglyphs were no longer in general use.
然后用两种古埃及文字：民众日常书写的通俗体，以及几个世纪以来一直让欧洲人困惑的祭司象形文字。正是罗塞塔石碑改变了这一切。虽然石碑本身的文字相当乏味，但它戏剧性地打开了整个古埃及世界的大门。到罗塞塔石碑制作的公元前196年，象形文字已不再通用。
They were used and understood only by the priests in the temples. 500 years later, even this restricted knowledge of how to read and write them had disappeared. The script of ancient Egypt was lost. The Rosetta Stone survived. unread through 2,000 years of further foreign occupations. Romans, Byzantans, Persians, Muslim Arabs and Ottoman Turks, all had stretches the rule in Egypt. At some point, the stone was moved from the temple at Saiz in the Nile Delta, where we think it was first erected, to El Rashid, or the town of
它们仅被神庙中的祭司使用和理解。500年后，即使是这种有限的读写知识也消失了。古埃及文字失传了。罗塞塔石碑在两千多年的后续外族占领中幸存了下来，未被解读。罗马人、拜占庭人、波斯人、穆斯林阿拉伯人和奥斯曼土耳其人都曾在埃及统治过一段时间。在某个时候，这块石碑从我们认为它最初竖立的尼罗河三角洲塞易斯神庙，被移到了拉希德，也就是我们现在所知的
Rosetta, as we now know it, about 40 miles away. Then, in 1799, Napoleon arrived. The French invasion was not only military but intellectual. With the French army came scholars. Soldiers rebuilding fortifications in Rosetta dug up the stone and the scholars knew immediately that they had found something of great significance. The French took the stone
罗塞塔镇，距离约40英里。然后，在1799年，拿破仑抵达了。法国的入侵不仅是军事上的，也是知识上的。随法军而来的是学者们。在罗塞塔重建防御工事的士兵们挖出了这块石碑，学者们立刻意识到他们发现了一些具有重大意义的东西。法国人将这块石碑
as a cultural trophy of war, but it never made it back to Paris. Pursued by Nelson, Napoleon was defeated and in 1801, the terms of the Treaty of Alexandria signed by the French, British and Egyptian generals, included the handing over of antiquities, and the Rosetta Stone was one of them. Most books will tell you that there are three languages on the Rosetta Stone,
作为战争的文化战利品带走，但它从未回到巴黎。拿破仑在纳尔逊的追击下战败，1801年，由法、英、埃三国将军签署的《亚历山大条约》条款中包括移交文物，罗塞塔石碑就是其中之一。大多数书会告诉你罗塞塔石碑上有三种语言，
but if you look on the broken side, you can see that in fact there are four, because there, stenciled on in English, you can read, captured by the British Army in 1801, presented by King George III. Nothing could make it clearer that if the text on the front of the stone is about the first European Empire in Africa,
但如果你看破损的一侧，你会发现实际上有四种，因为在那里，用英语刻着：1801年被英军缴获，由乔治三世国王赠送。没有什么比这更能清楚地表明，如果石碑正面的文字是关于非洲的第一个欧洲帝国，
Africa, Alexander the Greats. The finding of the stone stands at the beginning of another European adventure, the bitter rivalry between Britain and France for dominance in the Middle East and in Africa, which continued from Napoleon until the Second World War. We asked the Egyptian writer Adav Suef for her view of this history. So this stone so makes me think of how often Egypt has been the theatre of other people's battles. It's one of the earliest objects through which you can trace Western colonial interest in Egypt, because, of course, it was found by the French in the context of Napoleon's invasion of the country, and then appropriated by the British when they defeated him. And the French and the British argued over it, but no one seems to have considered that it belonged
即亚历山大大帝的帝国，那么这块石碑的发现则开启了另一场欧洲冒险，即英国和法国之间为争夺中东和非洲主导权而进行的激烈竞争，这场竞争从拿破仑时期一直持续到第二次世界大战。我们询问了埃及作家阿达夫·苏埃夫对这段历史的看法。她说：这块石碑让我想到埃及作为他人战场舞台的频率有多高。它是最早可以通过其追踪西方对埃及殖民兴趣的文物之一，因为当然，它是在拿破仑入侵埃及的背景下被法国人发现的，随后在英国人击败法国人时被英国人据为己有。法国人和英国人为此争论不休，但似乎没有人考虑过它属于
to neither of them. But Egypt's foreign rulers, from the Romans to the Turks to the British, have always made free with Egypt's heritage. Egypt, for 2,000 years, had foreign rulers. And in 52, too much was made of the fact that Nosser was the first Egyptian ruler since the pharaohs. And I guess we've had two more since, although with varying results. The stone was brought back to the British Museum and immediately put on display. In the public domain, freely available for every scholar in the world to see, and copies and transcriptions were published worldwide. European scholars now set about the task of understanding the mysterious hieroglyphic script.
他们中的任何一方。但是，从罗马人到土耳其人再到英国人，埃及的外国统治者总是随意处置埃及的遗产。埃及在两千年里一直有外国统治者。而在1952年，人们过分强调纳赛尔是自法老以来第一位埃及统治者。我想此后我们又有了两位，尽管结果各异。石碑被带回大英博物馆并立即展出。它进入公共领域，供全世界每一位学者自由查阅，其副本和转录本也在全球范围内出版。欧洲学者们现在开始着手解读神秘的象形文字。
The Greek inscription was the one that every scholar could read and was therefore seen to be the key. But everybody was stuck. A brilliant English physicist and polymath Thomas Young correctly worked out that a group of hieroglyphs repeated several times on the Rosetta Stone wrote the sounds of a royal name, that of Ptolemy. It was a crucial first step, but Young hadn't quite cracked the code. A French scholar, Jean-Françain-Françain, then realised that not only the symbols for Tolley,
希腊文铭文是每一位学者都能读懂的，因此被视为关键。但每个人都卡住了。英国杰出的物理学家和博学家托马斯·杨正确地推断出，罗塞塔石碑上重复出现的一组象形文字书写的是一个皇室名字的读音，即托勒密。这是一个关键的第一步，但杨并没有完全破解密码。法国学者让-弗朗索瓦·商博良随后意识到，不仅是托勒密的符号，
But all the hieroglyphs were both pictorial and phonetic. They recorded the sound of the Egyptian language. For example, on the last line of the hieroglyphic text on the stone, three signs spell out the sounds of the word for stone slab in Egyptian. A'hai. And then a fourth sign gives a picture showing the stone as it would originally have looked, a square slab with a rounded top. So sound and picture work together.
所有的象形文字既是图画又是语音。它们记录了埃及语言的声音。例如，在石碑象形文字的最后一行，三个符号拼出了埃及语中石板一词的读音。A'hai。然后第四个符号给出了一个图画，展示了石板最初的样子，一块顶部圆形的方形石板。所以声音和图画是共同作用的。
By 1822, Champolion had finally worked the whole thing out. From now on, the world could put words to the great objects, the statues and the monuments, the mummies and the papyrii of ancient Egyptian civilization. By the time of the Rosetta Stone, Egypt had already been under Greek rule for over a hundred years, and the Ptolemy's dynasty would last for another 150. The dynasty ended infamously with the reign of Clemeny. Leopatra the seventh, the Cleopatra, who beguiled and seduced both Julius Caesar and Mark Anthony. But with the death of Antony and Cleopatra, Egypt was conquered by Augustus, whose image I'll be
到1822年，商博良终于破解了全部内容。从那时起，世界可以为古埃及文明的伟大文物、雕像、纪念碑、木乃伊和纸莎草纸赋予文字含义。到罗塞塔石碑时期，埃及已经在希腊统治下超过一百年，而托勒密王朝还将持续150年。该王朝以克利奥帕特拉七世的统治而臭名昭著，即那位诱惑并迷惑了尤利乌斯·凯撒和马克·安东尼的埃及艳后。但随着安东尼和克利奥帕特拉的去世，埃及被奥古斯都征服，他的形象我将在
talking about later this week, and the Egypt of the Ptolemies became part of the Roman Empire. In the next program, I'll be in Rome's great contemporary, China, looking at how the Han dynasty operated a super-state and expanded their frontiers while keeping close control over every aspect of society. All this through a lacquer cup. Listen to the full 100 Objects series on Fridays right here in the 99% of visible feed. A history of the world in 100 Objects was a landmark collaboration between BBC Radio 4 and the British Museum. If you'd like to hear more of a history of the world in 100 objects, you can listen on BBC sounds in the UK.
本周晚些时候讨论，托勒密王朝的埃及成为了罗马帝国的一部分。在下一期节目中，我将前往罗马伟大的同时代国家——中国，看看汉朝是如何运作一个超级大国并扩张疆域，同时对社会的方方面面保持严密控制的。这一切都将通过一个漆杯来展现。请在“99%可见”频道每周五收听完整的《100件文物》系列节目。《世界历史：100件文物》是BBC广播四台与大英博物馆之间具有里程碑意义的合作项目。如果您想收听更多《世界历史：100件文物》，可以在英国的BBC Sounds上收听。
And if you're outside the UK, you can find it wherever you get your podcast. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您在英国境外，可以在您获取播客的任何地方找到它。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。